Self-driving cars are already here.
Widespread adoption of this technology will lead
to less traffic, less pollution,
and fewer car accidents.
These cars bring to life a
longstanding hypothetical dilemma -
how moral should we make our robots?
What if an autonomous vehicle
is faced with the choice
to either kill its passengers or kill others?
How should it be programmed?
In online surveys, participants approve of
autonomous vehicles
that sacrifice the driver to save many others
Basically a utilitarian approach that aims
to preserve the most amount of life
But respondents would prefer
not to buy these kinds of cars.
And, they don’t want regulations that
require self-sacrificing algorithms.
In fact, such regulations would make them
less willing to buy a self-driving car.
The rise of autonomous vehicles
creates a social dilemma:
Roads would be much safer
if there were more autonomous cars.
But programming that would
actually make driving safer,
might prevent people from
buying these vehicles
Imagine shopping for a car and having the choice -
a car that sacrifices the driver on occasion
or a “preserve the passenger
at all costs” car.
What would you do?